so you're not into the whole Disney what
they're doing you know the woke stuff
that this is what they do hasn't Disney
always been woke I mean my favorite
Disney movie when I was a kid was about
like a middle eastern dude which one
wasn't it
I didn't even know what he was I thought
Aladdin was white some brownies
like yo When We Were Young it was like
Mulan a lot I even know there was white
people in yeah there was one white it
was like Arielle was like a fish and
white yeah mermaid she was white and
white people the best swimmers like that
makes sense
yeah so it's like I I always thought it
was diverse I don't know why everybody's
making a big deal so you're saying
Disney's been woke for a while I would
even call it woke I think it's woke when
you like virtue signal about it like
nobody when when [ __ ] Aladdin came
out nobody was going oh here they go
trying to capitulate to the Middle
Eastern people you know like giving them
an opportunity I swear to God being a
kid
I didn't know that they weren't White
I mean I don't think you guys did you
even did you put a two and two together
and I'm Middle Eastern I wasn't like
yeah those sandals are dope like I
didn't I had no idea no I knew it was
Middle Eastern yeah yeah but we yeah but
yeah it wasn't it wasn't a problem until
you get older and where they they
separate Everybody by this and race and
this and yeah so what's happened then
Have We Become softer more sensitive
because you know there's a whole camp
that talks about what Disney's doing
right like their last two movies flopped
yeah this uh stranger World whatever the
movie was called that's a big one 180
million dollars opening weekend 20
they're saying they're going to lose 100
million then the other one they did is
uh which one is uh uh uh what do you
call it with Toy Story what's uh oh the
um well there's a name Buzz Lightyear
that one's flopped that's back to back
flop and the seal gets fired they lose
their tax status here in Florida so the
santis goes back with them Igor said a
couple comments the other day about the
Santas and uh you know it's it's a very
interesting place parents some parents
are not comfortable with Disney the
brands change a little bit but you know
they've had criticism for a while on
what they've done yeah yeah I think
yeah I think it's something that you
consider it's absolutely something these
these brands are considering right
you're a billion dollar company you're
going to make these considerations but
at the same time like they did that
thing I think Disney did Encanto yep was
that Disney that [ __ ] crushed killed
it and that's like a Venezuelan story or
something like that and I'm not exactly
sure so like
I don't know that's an interesting one
and it's written but like like you said
football's growing up we used to watch
what they would never make today Tom and
Jerry Road Runner and dude they were
trying to kill each other like you feel
me like the coyotes whole life was
trying to kill this [ __ ] Epic never
acne nothing ever worked and Tom and
Jerry this cat was trying to eat this
thing and was the worst
cat ever and the owner was a black chick
because you knew it yeah what you doing
that was the most blatantly like you
knew they never even showed who she was
she was a black chick and that was just
a stereotype black chick that they put
in I don't know I'm just I'm like Disney
you can't [ __ ] with the mouse man
Disney's just Disney's so smart like
people think it's a competition but it's
not like you'll spend you got kids you
have four kids yeah right yeah so like
you have kid no you don't [ __ ] boy
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we're talking about family values here
Disney Andrew Schultz yeah this is where
you want to go let me weigh out the
Disney songs let's talk about the
failure this is what I knew it was like
it was going to be rough for Netflix
when Disney got in the games because
like
have you ever been to Disney World okay
how much money you probably spend when
you go to dinner at least a thousand at
least a thousand give me all the kids
yeah at the hotel six thousand dollars
oh you're talking hotel and everything
every weekend yes four or five thousand
dollars at least four five thousand yeah
how much money will you spend on your
Netflix subscription over your whole
life oh great question that's a good
question probably less than that
I was in maybe yeah and you got six
different people using the same one like
so there's no way Netflix is going to be
able to compete long term with a brand
like Disney unless they start doing
these like live experience and things
and they have tried they're doing like
stranger things live right you got to
get people outside there has to be other
streams of Revenue like Disney's in
everything so even if they're not making
money off the movies they got money
coming in from Disney World Paris and
they got the merch lines it's like it's
so hard to compete with them so with all
the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetaining
it says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
our black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people were in the office they had
to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
look spread toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]